Jeff is with us in Frederick Maryland hi
Jeff how are you better than I deserve
what's up I had a quick question and I
was in a relationship and we have enough
time in where as a couple are starting
to make decisions for us rather than
individually and I was wondering in your
opinion should we go into your program
together you know make make each of our
debts one and cover it that way or do it
individually and support each other in
our different venture you should keep
them completely separate because the law
does okay you've got no protections and
it will really he could even start to
mess up and often does start to mess up
a relationship when you pay debts off
for somebody you're not married to the
person that's getting the debts paid off
feels weird and the person paying them
or the person paying them off feels
weird or their family members looking on
go this ain't right kind of things and
so you get all these other dynamics
going on it's different than when you
are married and so I highly recommend
you emotionally support each other and
encourage each other be each other's
cheerleader as they go along
but keep your debts separate legally
speaking you have a roommate until
you're married and if you were if you
were had a roommate in college you
wouldn't pay their debts you'd cheer
them on you cheer mom but you wouldn't
pay their dads and it's not a question
of love it's not a question of romance
it's not even a question of commitment
it's a question of how the law looks at
this and who's left holding the bag if
this deal breaks up and that is in the
back of everybody's mind and because
there's just no protection and they
eventually go through a divorce it's a
whole different thing
god forbid right and so um you know
marriage solves a lot of that so if
you're gonna act like you're married you
might as well be married as far as I'm
concerned but if you're not going to do
that I would tell you to keep everything
separate completely separate all your
business you have a roommate trigger
Mike a roommate that's what you're doing